so that's an example example one that's
the first reason why it's not called the
reverse part rule here's the next reason
example two integration by parts despite
the fact that it starts with the product
rule it's so powerful that it can help
you with things that don't even look
like planets okay now we don't know what
the integral of English sign is we don't
know yeah okay but integration by parts
will help us work it out now remember I
said you need to choose a U and a DV on
DX and it looks kind of like you don't
have many options but there is an option
right there is actually a product hidden
in here and I've used this every time
I've done a substitution this is sine
inverse times one so the question then
becomes well which one do I want to be
you and which one do I want to be DV o
DX keeping in mind this error like this
video I want you to try it out make a
choice you got a 50/50 shot and see if
you can get out an integral from the
other end altogether as soon as you
start writing your pair of primitives
and your pair of derivatives it becomes
obvious to you which one has to be used
and which one has to be DV on the X if
what you're choosing from is these two
write U has to be sine inverse Y well
okay so let's imagine if you're like
I'll just do it the other way and put
sine inverse here but to do integration
by parts you have to know what the
integral of that degree on the
excellence and that's what the question
is so sine you must clearly can't go
there that must be one can you fill in
the rest for me please
okay now being that we had no choice
that kind of makes the wall I guess I
guess that's what I have to do it's not
immediately obvious that this green
arrow is going to give you something
useful except it does that is actually
quite easy to integrate what are we
going to use reverse chain rule right
I'm going to do some substitutions I've
let u equal 1 minus x squared because
what's the derivative of 1 minus x
squared negative 2x which is just a
constant multiple of this right okay so
let's give this a go the integral of U
DV is equal to UV takeaway the integral
of VDU okay that makes sense so I've got
X on the square root of that makes sense
tell me you own your second one looks
like so that's my UV minus integral of
me do you what do I do now what did you
guys do with that integral yep okay so
if I do this then I can work out what do
you on DX use so then what does that
become
you've done it you thought another step
yeah I'll do that
yeah I probably should this is a bit
civic I see make it like okay now I'm
just going to I actually already have my
art so I've already integrated it I
think you come down to it's just the
atmosphere room it's just um this took a
lot because you need it because remember
this is to the power of negative half
yeah so then when you integrate up it
because the power half and then you have
to divide by that to the house okay okay
so you get to this again we is how do I
know I'm right bottom right let's do it
come on I choose I should guess an idea
okay so what on hold on hold on let me
catch up so I'm going to do I'm gonna
write this as a in index form yeah okay
so I've got a you and I've got a V so
what happens first V you - plus V - yeah
does that look at what about this guy
now the great thing is yeah if I did
this right it should be that but just to
confirm because I'm trying verify yeah I
don't wanna rely too much on myself I'm
going to do the inside first which is
negative 2x and then I'm going to do the
outside which is 1/2 1 minus x squared
to the power of negative 1/2 cancel
cancel this - exactly lined up with that
plus we've got X on the square root of 1
minus x squared so they're all goes yeah
um no I'm testing for us right now
because these are the first times we've
done it and also because we're not look
at the answer like I've already dropped
it off but I'm looking at the inside
like like this I have such a little
understanding of the integral of sine M
is next I'm like no idea where that
looks even remotely accurate but it's
just beautiful but it just it works it
works like what would have been and
otherwise I'm sorry I need to be taught
a form for this like I need to be given
a result and then I can do it
integration by parts has just taken
everything you've know not integrated
and just taking it to an an exponential
no I agree it wasn't entirely obvious
which one you should choose in this case
I chose u equals x which gives me into
you on DX and I chose this as DV on DX
now that's not obvious because you think
ah this is much more disgusting to
integrate than this okay but again the
key you see W be so proud of me the key
is the green error right the tree is the
VDU and what you get out of those when
you combine them it is actually more
useful for me to have a one there and it
is to have an x squared to here does
that make sense
because imagine I mean some of you
actually have done this some of you
started with this right as you so you've
got a derivative here which is what what
is that
minus minus 1 over 4 minus X to them the
square root of 4 1 Center yes so that's
what you've got here but then you get X
square on to over here and these two
can't work together you've got nothing
right so even though that is a bit gross
because there's only the derivative the
inside the integral of the entire
function it's just the constant right
no the dreaming I was right the first
time this is actually quite easy to do
when I do reverse chain rule what am I
going to get on this side
you're gonna get a negative from the
derivative the inside right this power
is going to go to three over two so when
you divide by 3 over 2 you get 2 over 3
4 minus X and there's that 3 of to talk
about ok now this when I do the green
arrow that V do you
I can still integrate that because it's
just as easy to integrate as this guy is
does that make sense so let's give this
a whirl the integral of U DV is equal to
u times this is me yep yep minus V sorry
the integral of V 2 times 2 u which is
just 1 with respect to X okay now here
it looks a bit messy but if you're
patient with that it's fine because
you've got up this guy at the front
minus 2x on three I'm just gonna leave
it in that index form because it doesn't
become immediately nicer indeed up what
happens with a derivatives ok so first
on is just like I did before
a - I dropped out the front which then
cancels with that beside this minus sign
stays intact is outside ok that 2 over 3
gets joined by r2 / 5 because this
becomes 5 over 2 so you divide through
so 2 over 5 and then what happens in
here 4 minus X and the power increases
what's the consulate yeah you should
have done so let's tidy this thing up
don't okay yeah you could yeah that
would be that would be slightly better
but there you go I'm happy with that and
that's that's the way you dressed my
part to take something like how else
would you treat this question here are
the parts but they're all but they're
all much more difficult okay and you can
see in even though the numbers are worse
it's a it's a small number of lines and
we get there and you if you want you can
differentiate it or you feel amazing you
can stick it into one from alpha and
you'll spit out the jury is
automatically